this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's
the ramsay show where debt is dumb cash
is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and host
of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today open phones at
triple
eight eight two 8255225
if ken coleman's in the house that means
you are more than free
to bring your career questions your
questions about
job hunts your questions about landing
in a position that you
have passion for as well as
get paid well for and all that kind of
stuff so ken's here to help and you
see you got a good opinion on that stuff
too dude i got an opinion about
everything
i know and i am an expert opinion yeah
but we get calls on the kick home show
about toxic culture what do i do i got a
a jerk boss but i've got i'm paying off
debt i mean dave gives a great
experience with that no stop it not true
you know but so many people are going
hey can i pay off debt and switch
jobs can i can i change careers while in
the baby steps so dave and i can take
that on as well
we can tag team yeah a lot of leadership
junk out there as well that affects
people's hey
is this the right place i'm doing the
right work maybe i'm in the wrong place
so
there's a lot of stuff we can take on
spousal hey my spouse is
is stuck how do i encourage the spouse
so a lot of questions we can answer
uh money and job related doing that
meaningful work
we're all here for you yeah the phone
number triple eight eight two five
five two two five and kelly has stepped
out in madison which is actually uh
ken's
assistant producer that's for phone
screener so she actually knows how
to uh screen calls for ken so she can
actually answer the questions as well
yeah she's heard them all kelly can
answer all my questions is that the
truth
and if you don't believe me ask her so
all right
genevieve is with us to start this hour
in los angeles hi genevieve how are you
i'm doing good i'm doing good so happy
to be on the call with you guys
you too what's up in your world all
right
so we have a duplex um we bought it
about
seven years ago and we owe about 287 on
it um
i guess i should start by saying i'm on
baby step two i have about 40 000
left to pay off in the combination of
student loans and
credit card debt that i refinanced and
we've been aggressively paying it for
the last two years about 60 000 has
already been paid
off and we were looking to refinance our
duplex
for a lower rate and a lower payment and
our loan officer just told us you know
what
have you thought about refinancing
pulling the cash out and reinvesting it
so
i'm wondering if that's a good idea it
has a positive cash flow right now
and um that's kind of where i'm at i'm
like do i continue paying off my debt
or go ahead and reinvest no well let me
just
tell you if you ask a loan officer if
you should borrow more money that's like
asking a dog if it's hungry
all right i had a pug dog and it would
eat itself
until it died if you didn't take the
food away from it and that's a loan
officer they will loan you money from
from today on and they always have a
good idea on how to raise their
commission
yeah so no yeah no you're not trying to
get into debt darling you're trying to
get out remember
yeah yeah and it's funny because we come
from a family of entrepreneurs and
investors and
and i'm just like i want to be zero um
but of course you know it's tempting
temptation is like you know can we
reinvest
you know later on yeah well the question
you have to ask yourself is what's the
shortest distance between where you
are and wealthy is it borrowing more
money
on the duplex and investing that or
is it getting out of debt and the actual
data says
it's getting out of debt
okay that's the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealthy and so if we're going to get
out of debt because it's the shortest
distance between where you are and
wealthy then getting into more debt
would be
oxymoronic wouldn't it yes
okay yeah so what's your household
income and how quick you're going to pay
off this 40k with your cash flow
oh within the year i like you that's
awesome
i like you so just refinance that
refinance that duplex put it on as short
a term as you can put it on
on as low an interest rate as you can
put it on and let's get that duplex paid
off now too
boom just like that one more loan
officer smack silly
i've been doing this 30 years and it
never gets old what is the score dave
ramsey
1 million to 0 on that one uh you know
what dave
seriously i want to ask you a psychology
question there because what happens is
she's she's doing the right thing she's
working the baby steps
paid off 60 000 40 to go within the year
they're debt-free
living like nobody else and she calls
the loan officer they do what they do
not demonizing but they're doing what
they're doing i will and
i know you will and it changes the
narrative so we have to switch the
narrative back and go
no i called to save money which is going
to help me get out of debt faster
because if i'm saving money
on the current mortgage payment uh it
means more money towards
the debt snowball and that narrative
just gets all jumbled in their minds
yeah it is human nature
and it is really actually intelligent in
a way
to look for the easiest route
we want the easiest route right and you
really should why would you take the
hard route if there's an easy one i mean
it's
intelligent to do that yeah you want to
take the easiest route but the in search
of the easiest route
we tend to it's all of us
tend to look for a pill if i could just
take that get out of debt pill
i'd be out of debt i could take that
lose weight pill i'd lose weight
if i could take that uh make my marriage
happy pill we don't want to do the stuff
uh you know no discipline seems pleasant
at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
human nature is
to look for the easiest route and that
leads us if we're not careful
over the precipice into the
get-rich-quick mindset
into the uh there's a shortcut right
everybody knows about but me that's
right and i think i found it that's the
truth there's
not one yeah there's no shortcut to any
place that's worth going
and that's the trap dave the progress oh
progress is smart so the very thing
that's not smart
it's dumb to do that take on more debt
it feels smart because it's progress
it fee well it feels like it's a shorter
yes okay it's a shortener quicker oh
that's an easier route
yeah and um because oh look i feel
better
all that debt's gone i don't think about
it and instead i gotta crunch and run
run and grind through the rest of the
year but then when it's gone it's really
gone
because see here's here's an interesting
fact about the math on this
you cannot borrow your way out of debt
that is true
let that one sink in yeah just get
that'll get you there in a minute if you
keep digging
you can't get out of a hole while
digging out the bottom and so you can
move your debt
to your home your duplex your you can
move it around that's what debt
consolidation does it allows you to feel
like you did something
but the debt is still there it just has
a new name that's right
it just moved it it's all you did so
please don't act like
you invented fire okay you didn't do
something that was really
you that's the but that's the that's why
i call it debt
consolidation here's here's how we know
that this is true
88 of people that take out a debt
consolidation loan
to end quotes air quotes pay off their
debt which it wasn't paid off it was
just moved
88 that's 9 out of 10 times
end up not changing their habits and
running up new debt
over there so they move the credit cards
over onto the second mortgage and now
they run up new credit cards because
they don't change the habits
88 nine out of 10 times but it felt like
you were doing something oh yeah very
smart this is a smart move i'm getting a
lower interest rate i've got our
interest rate really
better off lower interest rate it's all
about the interest rate it's not about
the fact that i can't
freaking stop my spending like i'm in
congress
and so and that's not genevieve this is
just a thing
this is the day we're this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
so
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host here today on the ramsay show
thank you for joining us the phone
number here triple eight
eight two five five two two five as we
talk about your careers your money your
life
anything you wanna talk about speaking
of careers here at ramsey solutions we
are
trying to do something pretty radical we
wanna transform
so many lives that disruption spreads
like wildfire across our country
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan
where the majority people pay cash for
their cars where the credit card has
become the cigarette of the financial
world
where living and working in a job that
you
love in a career field that you love and
prospering is
normal instead of statistically
philosophically unusual at ramsey
solutions that's why we have a thousand
people at this company working together
to create digital products and all kinds
of goods and services
to help people transform their lives
with the goal of disrupting this toxic
culture and if you don't think that the
culture in america is toxic you haven't
come outside lately
if you want to join us on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt for many
software engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp front-end
technologies
if you're a ux designer we need you seo
content marketing specialists
we'd love to talk with you digital
designers we're there baby
any just about anything we've got about
360 positions to fill this year
we are exploding here we're just
finishing up a new building next door
and that means there's room for people
it's that simple
so find out about all these
opportunities at daveramsey.com click
on the right hand side button it says
dave's hiring
if you're a senior level developer how
about this
when you teach people and mentor people
and coach people to write code they're
writing code
that changes people's lives not that's
going into a black hole
it actually matters oh and by the way we
go home at six o'clock we don't work you
80 hours a week
we have this weird idea that you should
actually be a good dad and a good mom
and be home with your kids and that's
really weird if you're in the technology
world
because they try to kill people in the
technology world it's almost like first
year law students isn't it
they just churn through them yeah churn
and burn baby
all right ashley's with us in sacramento
hey ashley what's up
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
um so i just have a question so
my husband and i were we're debt-free we
luckily
were able to get through school without
any debt
and my husband just landed his first job
out of school and he's making some good
money so we opened up
with his 401k and then also opened up a
roth
ira and we've been contributing a little
bit
but i know you recommend 15
to go towards retirement but we're also
trying to
save for a down payment so i was
wondering do you still
recommend the 15 while we're trying to
save for that or
is it okay to do a little less okay how
old are you guys
um i'm 21 and he's 24. okay
well first let's establish you've got
some time
there is not a rule that says you go to
hell if you don't buy a house by 25.
okay you're gonna be okay you're gonna
you got a little time to work on this
you don't have to panic
um you're gonna be just fine and you've
done a really good job
so far very well done all right two
things one is we teach a process called
the baby steps
one is a thousand dollars saved you've
done that two is debt free you've done
that
three is a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six
months of expenses have you got that
yes we do good excellent okay and what's
your household income
um so he's making sixty thousand i'm
still
job searching that's cool so what do you
think you'll be making when you land
something
um probably around 30. okay so you have
a roughly 100 000
income 90 to 100k right in there and
you're just beginning your career so
it'll go up that's excellent
okay now we teach after people are at
baby step three they have their
emergency phone and they're debt-free if
they
are ready to buy a home at that point
then you would save up your down payment
if you want to put your retirement
savings on hold temporarily we call
that baby step 3b baby step 3 being the
emergency fund 3b
be being saved for the down payment on
your home okay okay
and if you want to so if you want to sit
out of retirement for two years
or three years and pile up cash very
rapidly now the other thing i'm hearing
is i think i'm hearing you're not on a
written budget
and you guys need to get a detailed
written game plan
because uh you would have known exactly
what was going on you've got general
concepts and again you've done a really
good job but i want you to get in a
detailed written budget
jump on every dollar it's an app you can
download for free
and start to figure out how to put that
budget together or look at a free
uh trial at ramsey plus where you can
use the every dollar
premium budget version and get through
the classes as well
julie is with us julie is in nashville
hi julie how can we help
yes i have a question so for
accreditation at my job
the mean salary for my position is about
12k more than i'm making
and i have about two years before i can
make the next level
and i just wondered if i you know
talking about her ken saying
don't go after a raise about how you can
develop and grow
and so if i go and ask for a growth plan
should i mention
like you know i i know that because the
tables are posted like i'm less than
this
that i'm at the current salary you know
at my current position
um i do know that i for my location i
make
more money in the area than you know
other
jobs in the area okay yeah so
i didn't quite understand that last part
because i think it's got to be industry
specific so if you're trying to industry
specifically right
it's industry okay but what you're
seeing is the median across the nation
you're about 12 000 lower but not in
your area but not in your area
yeah yeah so my area for my area i'm
actually
higher okay but for my my specific
company
i'm actually 12k less than what they
post for my
title okay okay well okay so that's
great information
uh and so you're right i want the rest
of the audience to hear this dave i
don't like
people going in and asking for a raise
it puts your leader
in a very awkward position if there's
been no conversation there and so ramsay
solutions we've got a wonderful
wonderful
rhythm around this around growing and
that is we have
a very clear kra key results area it's
one page uh for everybody including the
personalities
and so there's clear uh goals there's
clear
boundaries for this is the work that i'm
responsible for these are the results
i'm responsible for and then we meet
every year an annual meeting of course
there's meetings all the time around
here with our leaders
but here's here's the deal i don't want
you to ask for a reason when you sit
down and say hey i want to grow
and i i know that i need to grow my
skills
i'd like to know from you if we could
get together don't put them on the spot
and say hey i'd like to have a meeting
soon where we talk about a growth plan
that includes me
adding some skills that you think maybe
i need to add
strengthening some areas where i'm i'm
good but i could be better to add more
value to the organization
and then you want to say hey as i want
to do those things i want to be measured
on that growth
and as a result i'd like to see how that
may lead to additional responsibilities
and more
influence in my position or in the
company
and and when i'm growing professionally
then that leads to a natural
conversation of growing
my income and so that's how i like
people to
to bring the leader in let the leader
have some ownership and speak
into your growth and i think because
you're in a situation
where you're paid you could go in with
information
and say hey here's what the median is
and i've done some research on this but
i
i don't like bringing that into the
conversation until there's a growth plan
that's agreed upon because here's what i
know dave in a healthy organization with
healthy leadership
they will respond the right way and
they'll say sure we can do that
and if they don't have the built-in
systems that we have at ramsey solutions
this can develop that and healthy
leadership will accept that and figure
that out if they don't already do it and
then the conversation david
is is it okay off the back end of that
conversation to say
because i noticed that i'm 12 000 below
the posted amount and i want to know
what i need to do to be worthy
that's it you bring that up after you
say hey i want to grow and make myself
more valuable to the company with your
measurement yeah and that's why
i do want them in that conversation to
recognize that she's being paid less
than their stated amount yes
absolutely that's a i would want to know
that as the leader but you do that in
the actual meeting that we described not
setting up the meeting yeah off the back
of the conversation not in the actual
meeting you're not opening the
conversation with that it's closing the
conversation with that yep that's
it that's i got it okay yeah because i
would want to know that as the leader so
i could make the adjustment because i
would go oh crap i didn't realize that's
exactly right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
i'm dave ramsey your host michael is
with us
michael's in boise idaho hey michael how
are you
i'm better than i deserve how about
yourself better than i deserve sir how
can i help
um i got a quick question for you my
wife and i are in baby steps four five
and six
and i've got some savings bonds that my
grandad gave me for my birthdays and
christmases growing up as a kid
they totaled about 900 so we're not
talking about a lot of money here but
i do want to honor my grandad with what
i do with this money so
i have a two-part question first would
be uh dave do you have a guiding
principle
on how to honor financial gifts given by
family members
who've passed away well i i always just
it's a general concept i always just
think well when i do this is he going to
be in heaven smiling
that's good that's really good and so
you know it might be that he told you
this is for your college
and it didn't ever end up getting used
for college for whatever reason
and instead he hated debt and you use it
to pay off a credit card
well he'd be smiling even though it
wasn't the original intent
because it but it matches with who he is
or was
right right you know so my granny used
to give us savings bonds all times for
our kids college
and of course they don't pay squat and
so as soon as i could get a hold of as
soon as i could get a hold of him
i and she she blessed her heart she
believed in savings bonds and she was
religious she gave those 50
100 200 to pop they're coming in for the
kids
and as soon as i could cash them out i
cashed them out and put them in a mutual
fund
and uh bless her heart i told her the
truth i did not lie to her she would say
how's those savings bonds doing i said
they're doing great granny
because they are they're now in a mutual
fund so they're actually freaking
producing something but i didn't give
her the details i just told her the
truth they're doing great now
because her intent was to help the kids
have some money for college
and her intent was uh what i did with
them
i i didn't go buy a steak at a steak
house
for myself that would not have made her
smile right
and then i would have had to lie to her
or the truth and she'd been mad or
whatever but
you know but but the point is you know
what's the right thing to do and
you know that's my guiding principle on
honoring whether they're alive or dead
but certainly where there's inheritance
what it does it keeps you from doing
something childish
like if your grandpa leaves you 100 000
in exxon stock and you go buy a used
lamborghini well that's
dumber than a rock yep you know
and that ain't going to make him smile
because he can't spell lamborghini i can
just tell you that
so you know i know i can't that's two of
us
michael well i mean that's the whole
thing so the the point is just
because when you get an inheritance you
kind of have it's like you said it's 900
it's not a lot of money but put a couple
zeros on it's 90 grand now okay
and so if it's 90 grand then you know
what you have is you have a little bit
of that lotto moment like
game on baby road trip you know and you
start thinking about what you're going
to do with this money that's really
irresponsible and mature
yeah i got a thought here michael i'm
just going to give you this and you take
this
um if it were me because of your
financial status
baby step four five and six you're
rocking it 900
is not going to make that big a
difference it's not like you it would
take care of a baby step
uh or excuse me a a debt in the debt
snowball
i i would ask yourself or maybe talk to
your mom and dad
what if you knew him well what what did
he love what fired his soul up was there
a cause was there an activity that
that he really loved and if it were me i
would do something really cool or
consider doing something really cool
with that 900
around that something because i heard in
your voice
you want to honor him and you're doing
such good with your finances 900 bucks
doesn't make a huge difference i love
you can use it in your baby steps and
keep on rolling or
you could do something cool here dave
that let's just say he was
he was into hunting or he he he was into
woodwork or something and you could
bless somebody maybe who's starting out
or
uh or or you know generosity moves
generosity
in the in the spirit of your grandfather
that he would smile from heaven on that
amen
erica's with us in fort lauderdale hey
erica what's up
hi dave hi ken uh first of all thank you
so much dave you changed me in my
husband's life
no you did i'm proud of you oh thank you
um so my husband and i um we are our
question is whether we keep our house or
not
we um we actually are in ministry we
live overseas
um right now in the caribbean and and
basically uh
we are we have a house in fort
lauderdale and
we're fully supported by churches so um
but the thing with our house right now
is it um
we're planning to stay where we are
maybe for the next five to nine years
we've come to that decision
so we have this house in fort lauderdale
and
it needs a new roof insurance isn't
paying for it so we can't go through
that
um it's south florida so taxes are
really high and we're learning about all
this we didn't realize this with taxes
and everything
um and so we're just considering selling
it yes
um yes okay
today wow this thing's not a blessing
it's a curse
it's not bringing you peace yeah that's
true
it's not it's not adding to your life
can you make money on it
yeah they'll make money on it you can
make money on can't you when you sell it
yeah yeah yeah dave yeah yeah i just
wanted to confirm that i mean so i think
i put some money in the bank to ensure
that to ensure that your missionary
endeavor doesn't run up underfunded at
some point yeah
and you all the missionaries keep this
is a problem as all the missionaries
tell us
and we just witnessed it don't tell your
house like this is the thing with
missionaries
they they don't have anything when they
go back so they're like don't sell your
house whatever you do so i think a big
part of us is like
if we sell it you know we don't want
that money that
well i i disagree with that sentiment
and i have told missionaries that for 30
years
that is a wrong statement you should
sell your house if you're going to be
gone five years you should sell your
house it take the proceeds
and take whatever you would have spent
on a house payment and
invest it in good mutual funds so that
you have a nice house fund
to buy a home when you come home
yeah but the idea that you need to keep
your property and try to be a
long-distance landlord
while you're trying to serve jesus in
the caribbean that is just dad gum hard
that just adds pain to your life not
blessings yeah scarcity versus abundance
you're not going to be homeless when you
come back yeah you can especially
you need to have a plan to have a home
when you come back so that part
that's what's driving them to make the
statement of never sell your house
because they're afraid they're
not going to have the money to buy a
house because they've never saved
anything
so if you don't plan to have a home when
you come back
by investing then you then then you've
made a real mistake
but you need to plan by continuously
investing to be ready to return
let's run the numbers out on that dave
because i think it was great advice i
mean just a ballpark number let's say
they make a hundred grand on their house
or 150 and they put it in a mutual fund
she said they're going to be there five
to nine years
she puts in a good mutual fund that
becomes that housing fund if all of
their other expenses on the mission
field are covered that becomes a sizable
down payment
it'll double yeah it'll double in about
seven years that's the narrative again
that's not happening
yeah but if you take that money and
spend it to live on the mission field
and you have
zero money and zero house and you come
off yeah
that's the fear that has created this
thing oh never sell your house when you
go in this field
now if you're going to mission field for
six months that's a different thing
these people are going to be gone
five seven years ten years whatever so
that's a different that changes the
equation as well
kimberly is in san bernardino california
but we're going to come to her after
this commercial break i just looked up
and saw
the uh i saw the clock creeping up on us
homeowners insurance can be one of those
set it and forget it kind of things when
you first bought your home you may have
just gone with whatever coverage the
lender had or
the realtor suggested or whatever you
need to get your insurance re-quoted
go to one of our endorsed local provider
insurance agents they are independent
brokers they will shop among several
different companies
and get you the best possible price on
your home or
auto or both the average person coming
in
uh to this saves about 700 a year and
the quote to get how much does it cost
to get a quote
nothing it's free so text the word home
to 33 789 you need to continuously check
on your insurances to make sure you're
not being
over charged one thing she was just
talking about was the cost of insurance
in south florida it's very real
so text home to 33
789 home to 33789
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today you can hear the ken
coleman show
on sirius xm as a podcast we're at about
75 radio stations around america so be
sure you tune in
he speaks every day to people all over
america about how to get and keep
the best career path that puts you into
what he calls your sweet spot living
your passion kimberly is with us in san
bernardino california hi kimberly how
are you
good hi dave i had a question
me and my husband are kind of debating
our question is should my husband take a
new job
and depending on the retirement we don't
know a lot about retirement so we don't
know the questions that we should ask
he currently has a job where he has a
tier one and tier two that he pays him
to he works for the railroad
so the new job from what we know
that he was offered does not offer
retirement but they match six percent i
don't know
what questions to ask to make a wife's
choice okay
um well i mean if if they're if they
have a 401k that they match in six
percent that sounds like a fairly normal
company type position versus the
railroad which has a very unusual
retirement system okay okay so what does
your husband make at the railroad
he you want to know hourly no annually
okay i have the paper in front of me so
annually um
i don't okay so annually it shows i
don't think it has one here
so i'm thinking around what does he
bring what's he bring home a month or a
week or whatever
okay so he gets paid every two weeks
about
twenty one hundred dollars one thousand
after ten
yes twenty one hundred dollars and so
forty two hundred dollars a month
so forty eight thousand dollars a year
and so he's making about 60 65
000 depending on what's coming out of
his chat okay
correct okay now what's the new job pay
25 an hour so whatever that is times 80
times i don't know what that is
but um 50 grand okay thank you a guy in
the lobby just helped me all right
so uh you're gonna make about the same
or a little bit more
at the new job okay right okay now the
question here though is
how old is he my husband's 30.
okay so when he's 60 old like me
what's he gonna be glad he spent the
last 30 years doing
which one of these what i think
saving for retirement paying off no no
no no no no that wasn't what i was
talking about
can this is yours yeah so here's the
thing
we've got the numbers right he's making
60 to 65 now on the railroad
this new job is going to pay him about
50. so it's a pay cut
if we got those numbers right so that's
the first issue but what dave was asking
is why does this guy want this job why
does your husband want the job does he
want it because he loves the work
it's it's work that matters to him and
long term hates the railroad yeah why
does he want to
what's the what's the reason for the new
job with the railroad he can't go up
anymore so that's the top okay good so
he's captain good job
yes correct so with the new job he does
start off at 25 but after three to six
months he goes back to 32.
there we go now now we're moving the
right direction so this is a temporary
pay cut
for the opportunity to advance not just
financially but also professional
what would he be doing at the new job um
so far what i know it's called the
operator d
so it's borax i don't know if you guys
ever heard of borax it's called boron
rio tinto
so they um it's a mine and they do
minerals so
he would be packaging shipping out
minerals
everything to do with it's not
under the ground mine it's above the
ground it has to do with the minerals
they put in electronics
when he talks to you when he talks to
you about it what do you think his
excitement level is
sorry what do you think his excitement
level is when you hear him talk to you
about this new job
on a scale of one to ten one no
excitement ten he's throwing a party
what's his excitement level when he
talks to you about this new job
10. then it's a no-brainer so you guys
don't
need to plan for the short term not
retirement
dave will answer that listen you take
the 401k you get out of debt you do your
baby steps
maybe step three is in place of three to
six months of expenses you're debt-free
and then you put 15 of your income away
for retirement and you will retire
wealthy
15 you need to put 15
of your income away for retirement and
they're going to match another six
and so you're going to retire wealthy if
you do that
okay so you're fine you're not you're
not you are not
going to retire and have to eat alpo
that's right
okay good now here's here's the other
thing never
take a job ever ever just for the money
never take a job ever because of the
freaking benefits package that's true
always take a job because it has a
bright
future and makes you smile doing the
work
yes this is the way you make a decision
on a job
not based on the freaking 401k match
that's exactly right now
let's go back into our baby steps dave
let's walk let's walk other people
through this because this call
we get this a lot on the ken coleman
show i know a lot of people listening
watching right now
are feeling this too so this is a
temporary pay cut okay
so in three to six months he's gonna go
from 25 an hour
to around 32 an hour so they need to get
back into their budget and go okay
we have to plan for a temporary
pay cut but it's temporary so we got to
adjust the budget
we plan for this and we absorb this your
thoughts on that yeah absolutely
absolutely don't act like it's not
happening yeah because they only end up
you know i ran up five thousand dollars
in credit card debt because we took a
pay cut
you know that's just that's dumber than
a rock don't do that so you got a plan
this is gonna happen it's to happen so
plan on the
drop in pay make sure you're going to br
lower your lifestyle to fit that
and then you can then you can begin your
investing process later but yeah
railroad retirement is incredible it is
not
so incredible that you should keep a job
making absolute
ceiling on your ability to progress and
keep a job that you don't like doing
yeah this is important to point out that
you know
when it's time to consider moving on
when you have been told and it's been
made obvious to you that you've hit your
lid now you've got to sit back and go
okay
am i okay with this lid because dave you
know this we as humans are creatures of
progress
it's just wired into us by our creator
we want to make
progress we want to grow uh some people
have gone so far as to say if you're not
growing if you're not learning you're
dying
now you there are some jobs where you go
hey this is it
and i'm good here and this is it but for
those of you who want more in your work
and you're in an environment where
because of the organization or the
leadership
there is an artificial lid on you you're
not moving up
it's time to start thinking about moving
on
absolutely that'll wear on you jeff is
in raleigh north carolina hi jeff what's
up
i'm doing well how about you guys good
how can we help
so i'm curious i have 61 000 in a ira
rollover account from previous work
history
i'm curious if i should roll that into a
roth ira
uh i'm in baby step two no
because you're gonna you're gonna create
twelve thousand dollars worth of taxes
to add to your baby step two
so i am um hear me out for a second
so i i was 17 five on my truck
i have fifteen five in savings and i'm
getting
ten thousand dollars back uh in taxes
this year
so that's gonna wipe out my debt we'll
be on baby step three
good and you still don't have you still
don't have an extra fifteen thousand
dollars to pay the taxes
uh so my numbers if i moved half of it i
would get
just stop okay i would not do this
okay i would i it's an old 401k is that
what you said
yes i would roll it to a traditional ira
in good mutual funds
later on in your wealth building i would
convert it to a roth
in a few years after you get the house
paid off and do some other things and
you've got some extra cash laying around
but when you throw 15 000 or whatever
at this you know a fourth of it's gonna
be taxes roughly
at this account because you're rolling
it to a roth
then that's money you could have used to
build your emergency fund
build your kids college fund get the
house paid off and some things you
should do before
you send the government money and so i
instead would just
move it to a traditional ira and let it
sit there and grow in some good mutual
funds
and convert it to a roth later
you need the fifteen thousand dollars
that you would be spending on taxes to
do things that are more important than
this becoming a roth
today it's a matter of priorities you do
what you want
but that's what you asked this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as
the status symbol of choice can coleman
ramsey personality
and career expert host of the ken
coleman show author of the number one
best-selling book the proximity
principle
is my co-host today so you've got
questions about career about jobs well
you can mix those in with the questions
where we talk about life and money
the phone number triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and
is with us in orlando florida hi ann
welcome to the ramsey show hello thank
you so much for taking my call
sure what's up um well i'm a widow
and i just am really concerned about my
debt my future
on a positive i just received a ten
thousand dollar check in the mail
on the opposite end my primary mortgage
was just sold to a lender that i'm not
comfortable with
i need a new roof and i have a heloc so
i'm considering refinancing
all of that together it would also be at
a much significant
interest rate and then for the and then
taking that ten thousand dollar check
and throwing that at the credit card and
i have a bonus check
next month that i think will take care
of the one other debt that i have
is that a good plan to get me set up so
that i can retire
well in the future how old are you i'm
53.
okay and what do you make about 63 a
year
okay when's your husband pass he passed
five years ago
[Music]
i'm sorry um sounds like you are really
on top of things
proud of you very well done i like mine
i have my moments
i like everything in your plan except
borrowing to do the roof
okay so your plan is really good you
need to get rid of that he locking that
higher interest rate mortgage by
refinancing and get a cheaper rate i
love that part of the plan
that's really good the ten thousand
dollars towards the credit cards makes a
lot of sense is the roof leaking
it is not um but locally a lot of the
insurance companies
are requiring that people re-roof their
homes and
the roof on my house is probably about
20 years old so it's getting about time
that it's going to need to be done
okay do you have a bid on it i have
people coming out next week to give me
bids
okay how big a house is it
um it's uh 20 it's 2300 square foot but
i
also have a 600 square foot lanai and
that just has a different type of roof
yeah is it asphalt shingle roof
yes it is okay all right cool you make
63 and you have
how much your credit card debt there are
17 on the card
okay and that's your only debt other
than your home
i have one other debt i i still have
1200
left on the monument um for our
gravesite
and anticipating being able to pay that
off next month with my with a bonus
check
okay how much is your bonus check don't
be um it varies
um but it generally it should be about a
net of
thirteen hundred dollars okay all right
so we've got
counting the ten thousand we've got
eleven thousand three hundred dollars we
got a twelve hundred dollar bill and a
seventeen thousand dollar bill
right yes okay so let's get in attack
mode knock the little bill out and let's
get those credit cards knocked out make
sure they're cut up
finish paying off that debt build your
emergency fund
and then build your roof fund
refinance your first and your second
together i i don't want you going into
debt
further on this house because part of
your retirement plan is getting this
house paid off
um yes it is i have a whole lot of
equity in the house
and i should still be able to get the
house paid off in 15 years
yeah well you i i yeah you're going to
because you're not going to borrow for
the roof
yeah so yeah we're going to put this on
a 15 year
and you're going to be done with it
sooner than that and you're going to
save up and pay cash for this roof and
you're going to be able to make all of
that work because you're going to lay
out a detailed plan
and um the good news about you is you
are
really paying attention i'm very proud
of you
there's not anything happening on
accident here you've spent a lot of time
thinking about this
and it led you to really good
conclusions except for that one detail
and so you know you really have done you
know you did
really smart when you came on the air
but everything you're going doing is in
the right direction
joseph's in kansas city hi joseph what's
up
good afternoon gentlemen yes sir honor
to be talking with uh with you and
ken on the show today this is more of a
mindset question
more than do we have the funds okay um i
have actually been unemployed for 10
months my wife has been working
i do collect i do collect
basically we've saved money aside to
build a home and uh
we're having a we've been saving for
over 20 years to actually buy
or build a newer home and now it's come
time
i've been i inherited property three
years ago
and it was actually burned down b's
property but
beautiful piece of land and you know we
currently own the hall
our home now we have absolutely no debt
live in old
dave ramsey way you know our newest cars
from 1999 that we keep it running
so you know we're looking for for
actually some guidance beyond family
because everyone else in the family says
live on debt we do not believe in that
at all we have absolutely no debt
so regarding this it's more of a mindset
question
we uh we've been saving for 20 years we
can
actually we have the cash to build the
home but we're just having such a hard
time
of actually finding that contract to go
ahead and begin to build
why because it's been over 20 years
of saving living very frugal way below
our means which would make me want to
sign that contract and get this crap
done
that's a good point dave and yeah you
know uh
both of us we've never made more than 20
bucks an hour
uh the house bill itself is going to be
about 240
000 how much does it say uh we currently
have
416 000 cash in retirement we have 308
000.
okay so um what is it that's scaring you
it's the fact of
i just have not ever made a whole lot of
income and it's going to take a long
time to replace
that 230 240 000 that we're going to be
spending
so primarily it's a matter of finding
another
position i'm actually starting my own
investment advisory firm i've been
financial coaching no fee for years
and it's something that i love to do but
i'm still looking for employment
and well if you want to wait until you
get employment and that gives you the
sense of stability to do this that would
not be illogical
yeah but joseph here's the deal you got
plenty of money
but if if if that's the last emotional
hurdle
hurdle uh that says you know i really
want to have a job before i break ground
on this thing
there's nothing that says you have to
start today
right and uh dave i gotta address this
joseph when dave asked you point blank
what the fear is
it's it's i've saved so much money over
so
long a period of time and once i spend
it on this house
it's gone and it's not let's say that 10
15 years from now you want to sell that
house that's going to appreciate you
paid cash for if i'm understanding that
right that money's coming back and then
some
yeah and the home you're getting that is
perfect yeah yeah and the home you're in
is paid for and it turns into a really
nice rental property i suppose
uh yes sir it's actually it's this
little two-bedroom home
uh you know joseph rental property do it
you're ready to go if you want to wait
till you get a job that's fine
but you're ready to go there's nothing
financially out of place here it's just
hard
you're right it's hard to turn loose so
it took you a long time to get here
and you kind of like that pile of money
being there yeah and uh
that's a normal human reaction so but
it's
you did it you you this is what you did
it for now enjoy the fruits of your hard
work and discipline
[Music]
cliff and i joined christian healthcare
ministries because we really liked the
concept
of christians sharing each other's
burdens
and we really experienced that firsthand
when cliff
was diagnosed with heart disease
christian healthcare ministries
or chm is not health insurance
but rather a federally approved
exemption to the health care law
it's a time-tested model to help take
care of your health care costs
it's christians helping other christians
by sharing each other's medical bills
adjusting to a new system of paying for
health care
was kind of tricky but that's where chm
stepped in
and they really helped navigate that
water
with the hospital and the payment want
to see if chm is the right fit for your
healthcare needs
check out our website at
chministries.org backslash budget
that's chministries.org backslash
budget it was just such a relief to know
that financial burden was going to be
taken care of
[Music]
ken coleman ramsay personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple h 8 2 5
5 five two two five amelia is in boston
hi amelia how are you
hi dave hi ken i'm well thank you for
taking my call sure
what's up um so i'm calling in today to
get some guidance on
getting on the same page with money as
my grandmother
actually she has given me a very
generous gift
and put it in a trust for me of a
hundred thousand dollars earmarked for
tuition and for a purchase of my first
home when the time comes
so we've taken chunks out of that over
the years for tuition and there's about
seventy five thousand
left i personally outside of that i'm
just about to finish baby step
three so i'm looking to purchase my
first home in the next
one to three years now the question here
that's causing some
uh contention and disagreement is that
that money is all invested in the market
mostly in index funds right now and with
me wanting to use it in the relatively
short term
my position is that we should take it
out and have it in cash well my
grandmother's position
is you know it's done well it's earned
great returns over the last several
years
why would we not want to continue that
so i'm looking on guidance as to
how to have that conversation and do
what i believe is the right thing with
this money while
you know still being extremely grateful
for the gift
she gave you the money and she put it in
trust and she's managing the trust
correct she's a bit of a control freak
i think with money it's mainly a
position of experience you know i'm
22 she's 74 so
she's got a lifetime of experience and
it does seem to me a bit controlling you
know i'm
a natural saver been financially
responsible for my whole life
you're in control and the money was
given to you to buy a house
and you can't take it out and buy a
house with it
right i don't understand
yeah uh i mean that's that's the point
that i'm stuck at is
how to have that conversation um so are
you when are you gonna buy a house
um probably in two or three years why
two or three years
uh because i'm not sure that i want to
stay in this area long term
so uh you know i'm waiting to get a
little confidence there before i make
the financial commitment to a house
okay well this is more of an issue of uh
you know puppet master than it is actual
financial advice
right yeah and so that you know you just
got to decide which hill you want to die
on um as far as the you know her advice
goes it's not the end of the world okay
let's say that those
index funds went down ten percent during
that three years
which would be one of the worst three
year periods in the stock market's
history
sure then you would have lost seven
thousand dollars right yeah it's it's
not end of the world either way
yeah and so and if it goes up ten
percent during that time you would have
made seven thousand dollars
so you know you your
of this money not of this money being in
the market
is not substance shouldn't be
substantial because the actual dollar
figures aren't going to be substantial
her wanting to take advantage of the
market
is almost laughable because it's also
going to be about seven thousand dollars
right it's a philosophical thing
you know is really all it comes down to
so
you know it and that reveals
that you guys are both being drama
queens about this
yeah but that's fair to say um yeah it's
you know
it's not a big deal either way but it's
difficult to have the conversation
yeah it's just like it's a control
conversation
it's a puppet master conversation and
you know so
like i don't know if this woman is
actually going to release this money
when you're ready to buy a house i can't
tell
yeah i'm sometimes worried about that um
because she's actually taken out the the
growth that's already come under the
account
over time so yeah
yeah oh she took it out and used it
herself yeah wow
yes which i mean the original balance is
still there so that was her call but
wow yeah that was not something i was
about to say just a little strange
so here's what i'm gonna do i'm just go
about the business of building up your
own down payment
and then if that money's there and she
wants to give it to you fine if not just
tell her to keep it
yeah absolutely that's fair enough
that's pretty much the plan
uh either way yeah because i i don't
think you're going to win this argument
one more thing
because the problem with her actually
letting you buy a house with a 75 000 is
that's the last conversation she has
where she gets to tell you what to do
and she really likes telling you what to
do
so i okay so i got to ask you this i'm
surprised at your answer
i was a little surprised is it great i
mean it's dead on but i thought
don't you just die on that hill with
grandma you told me this is what it was
for
i'm not going to fight with you and ruin
our relationship but that's what that's
it
yeah i mean because listen you can hear
what's happening with this lady
and there is no winning the argument
with this woman 100 agree
okay so why have the argument because
you're not gonna win it right you're
either gonna sever the relationship
over seven thousand dollars and the
money's not the thing
it's the control mm-hmm and um so
and then the other side of that is if
i'm making a gift if i'm the grandma
okay i've often said on here you're
gonna get my money you're gonna get my
instruction
okay but i have never given someone a
gift
and then managed it right
that's not a gift yeah that's that's
controlling so that's
you know but i i would say i'm not going
to give you this gift if you're not
doing these things
but once it's given you need to take
your hand off of it i agree
and uh you're saying don't even try to
have the conversation and go hey listen
i don't want to fight i don't want this
to go
grandma i love you and thank you for the
money and i hope it's there if you still
want to do it when we get ready to buy a
house that'll be fine because we're
going to go ahead and start building up
our own down payment
i know you'll be proud of us when we did
that i love you thank you
and just keep moving because what it
does just takes all of her power away
and she really is a lot about power
that's true what happens when gra if
grandma dies before this
i suspect the trust has terms that leave
it too that would beneficiary of the
truth
is amelia okay that okay yeah that's
good i needed to process through that
because sometimes it's like
principal let's have the conversation
and i think you're right now as i
process what you said it's like i'm
channeling my inner john d'alone
just tell them you love them and keep
going i think you're right i was
wondering
though i was like okay you're trying to
be nicer dolone's inspired me to be
nicer
he's very nice he is a nice very in
touch with his feelings and ours
he's in touch with everyone's feet he
really is he really is that's good and
he has a lot of feelings
yes he's not even here to defend himself
i'm ragging on him no he's awesome man
he's
he's great i love it regina is in
nashville hi regina how are you
fine dave hi uh thanks for having me on
the show hello
uh ken also how are you guys doing today
great how can we help you we're short on
time go straight to it
okay straight to it um all right i'm
unemployed my husband just got a job
about three weeks ago we moved
from uh california to the murfreesboro
area
in october i'm having a heck of a time
finding a job we owe a ton in taxes and
our finances
are a mess what did you used to do
uh well my last position i was an office
assistant
i've basically been in office for about
the last 20 years
uh my goal is to become a loan signing
agent within the next couple of months
so i'm looking for you know something to
tide me over until
that can be enough of an income so that
i can do that
well then here's what you do so regina
let me let me encourage this is a really
good job market in tennessee and
certainly in the greater nashville area
and you need to be just getting a job or
two right now you've got an income
problem and so you can drive you can
deliver pizza you can show up and work
at a grocery store you can work at a
warehouse don't just limit yourself to
office management positions when
that's going to be a short term play it
seems like for you anyway right now
this is urgency and so we're going to go
get a job two job three jobs
just go get a job get stable
and then get back up on the horse
towards that purposeful plan
do anything yes so that you can do
anything later
that's right work like a crazy person
and yeah
there's positions out there lots of them
in the murfreesboro area murphy's
booming booming but you need to broaden
your focus to almost anything
instead of so narrow so you get landed
in get the wolf away from the door
because you got this wolf howling
outside and it's driving you crazy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five
jonathan and rachel are in bowling green
kentucky says on my screen you guys are
ready to do a debt-free scream what's up
hey how are you great how much debt have
you guys paid off
we've paid off a hundred and two
thousand dollars in two years so 24
months
way to go and your range of income
during that time
so we started at about um 75 000
um by the time we were done we were we
were around about 115
000 and now we're back down to about 70
000 but that'll be going up soon we hope
good good deal so what do you guys do
for a living
um i'm a dental hygienist and i work for
ups
very good but while we were paying off
our debt um
i was a dental hygienist but me and
jonathan we both worked at a
um at a restaurant together he was the
kitchen manager and i
was a waitress which i've done for
several years and we worked
countless hours between the two of us we
usually worked about 60 to 80 hours a
week so it was
wow how old are you guys
um we're both 29. very good and how long
you've been married
oh this year will be eight years we've
been married yeah so what happened two
years ago that lit you up you got on
fire
um well it's funny i i was scrolling
through
um facebook one day and we watched uh i
watched a youtube video of someone doing
their debt free scream and
i just remember thinking there's no way
we could ever do this
but i went ahead and bought your book
and it literally took me a whole year
before i picked it up and read it
it makes a great coaster on a coffee
table
it actually was um and so i read the
book and the next day i came to jonathan
and i was like
listen i think this is what we need to
do and first he was like okay we you
know
we can do it and then you know it was
hard at first and then one day i came to
him i was like listen we cannot be
working in restaurants for the rest of
our lives
not what we want to do and he was like
okay we'll we'll buckle down and we did
so and that was two years ago that you
went crazy
it was two years ago that we went crazy
yep we remember every moment of it
yeah and you did 50 000 a year for two
years that's impressive
i mean you've been on beans and rice
rice and beans for sure
we sure did there was many many times we
worked
seven days a week for the most part
you know with jonathan he would get up
some days at um
six a.m to go to work and we wouldn't
leave until one a.m uh for the
restaurant so it was
it was rough yeah and it's over
it's over will you ever go back in debt
oh never again
never again what kind of debt was this
um it was several things we had student
loans mostly
and then cars and credit cards not a
whole lot of credit card debt though
and we had a little bit of medical debt
i think mostly it was um
our student loans and car loans so we
had a lease at the time which was
very dumb yeah wow i'm so proud of you
guys
well done thank you you are not afraid
of hard work
and when you get absolutely not and
you're not afraid to work together and
these are very
important things so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
because you did it
honestly it's just staying focused it it
really
i don't know i tell people it really
wasn't that hard once we put our minds
to it you know we we worked a little bit
more but we were already working so much
that it just
you know it kind of after a while it
came natural it was actually kind of fun
you know every month we'd just pay off
i mean more and more would go towards
the snowball and it was just it was
it was kind of fun wow well done well i
want to ask a question to both of you
because
this is this is something that i think
people need to catch
the fun part was the momentum each month
but there have got to be times when
you're working that kind of schedule
where you go
i know why we're working this hard i
don't ever want to have to work this
hard again
am i right you are absolutely right um
jonathan's been lucky going from working
80 hours a week to
until he starts in his full-time
position at his job he's down to 20
hours a week and this is
everything he's ever dreamed of with the
work last
well i'm hoping you've taken a few naps
jonathan because you've earned
every day all good okay that's good to
know that's good
that's so great well done you guys who
were your biggest cheerleaders other
than the two of you
oh gosh definitely my mom for sure um
your parents yeah my parents both of our
parents have been really supportive
through the whole process
we we really didn't have you know i know
a lot of people
that go through the debt-free journey
they have some naysayers we really
didn't we had everybody was
so proud of us on board with it so that
helped so much my mom and dad i mean
my dad would would text me or message me
every so often how much longer how much
longer i'm like we're getting there
we're working on it
i'd love to ask both of you how is your
relationship grown
when you've come together so intensely
on such a big goal and work so hard how
is your relationship your marriage grown
i'd say it's definitely grown a lot
closer we've always you know had a great
relationship but
uh it's just a lot of give and take and
a lot of working together and this has
definitely helped to help
strengthen that i feel like i mean i
think it's helped us a lot because we've
been able to we knew we were putting in
an equal effort you know
nobody we didn't give up on each other
we didn't you know as many times as we
wanted to say okay well let's go buy
this it's like no
i mean if if you don't get something
then i'm not going to get something so i
think that really really helped you know
it helped strengthen our relationship it
helped us keep us motivated so
what are you dreaming about they're
hearing that people are hearing this
story
they're watching this on youtube what
are you dreaming about now that you're
on the other side of this
as a couple um well we eventually want
to have kids so
that'll be you know we wanted to kind of
get out of debt to do that but
our most reachable dream right now we
need to fix our shower so that's what
we're saving for now that's our dream
all right we'll take the little dreams
that's good that's good that's a good
first step
well done you guys very well done
your impressive young rock stars yeah
you got a bright future ahead of you you
know how to work together and you know
how to work
and uh and you know how to execute and
lay out a plan and execute on it you can
do that with any part of your life now
and you'll be able to do this for the
rest of your lives
absolutely very well done excellent
excellent work new grooves
are in your brain you are ready to rock
we got a copy of chris hogan's book for
you
everyday millionaires that is the next
chapter for you
and uh let's count it down i love it 102
000 paid off in two years making 75 to
115
a lot of work jonathan and rachel
bowling green kentucky count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
all right
[Applause]
thank you well done you guys we're so
proud of you
excellent you know we had
some uh friends over for dinner the
other night a couple
two couples and we were telling old
stories from when we were that age
because that's the age we were when we
were bankrupt and uh
the guys like one of the one of the men
sitting there was
quizzing sharon he was doing the
interview routine right and uh getting
her side of the story
yeah because everybody everybody hears
my side of the story and sharon
is great people don't realize how fun
she is when she answers questions
she's like oh is the yellow pad
and he said what do you mean she said
well when we we make a
we every night we sat down with this
stupid yellow pad
and wrote out a plan of what we were
going to do
this week next week and what we're going
to do 10 years from now
and she said we kept writing that yellow
pad and we kept writing that yellow pad
and we were you know the way we got
through bankruptcy
and the way we rebuilt our lives was
with a freaking plan and doing it
together
and it's a yellow pad and you know she
can see it in her head and i could see
sit i
remember that little oak table we're
sitting that little oak pedestal table
and we're sitting there with that yellow
pad going okay next thing's fixed the
shower that's what made me think of it
you know it's stuff like that the first
thing you know you know before you start
talking about
being a millionaire you fix the shower
that's the truth i thought it was a
great answer because that's the show's
the sacrifice yeah
they literally rice and beans working
themselves
no this is awesome look great great
couple because that's exactly what we
did we had
you know we had to fix the roof we had
to fix the heat in there dad gum air
conditioner was out
you and i talked about this a lot how
good is that shower gonna feel it
not because it's working yeah but
because of how hard but if you went down
to home depot and put it on home depot
card
oh it would spit acid on you yeah it's
the truth be like
shards of glass it will never work
[Laughter]
oh my goodness uh this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is
my co-host today as we talk to you about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five scottie is with us in
west
palm beach hey scotty how are you i'm
great
dave and uh ken both of you thanks for
taking my call here and helping me out
sure how can we help i'm a new sole
proprietor
and i set up my business checking and
savings account
good but um the bank named both of them
as my dba
and i was under the impression from you
that that should have like
you know xyz corp tax savings account or
something to that
uh effect oh no no it doesn't have to be
named to that by the bank you just gotta
nickname
it that on the file oh
okay because i didn't want you know the
irs to say well you have a checking name
for you and you have a savings name
no no the irs the irs never sees any of
that
all we're trying to do is make sure you
set aside money out of your profits
for taxes so you can pay your quarterly
estimates and you just need a savings
account to do that
and by that i mean a separate savings
account that you're not saving for
something else in and so you
accidentally spend your tax money when
you buy the something else
right and that's what i've done yeah
they're totally separate so then the
next the last question is
after i take that 25 out since i'm just
a sole proprietor what's the best way to
pay myself or just off the the business
the the debit card
or or do i really need to set up with a
payroll company
no you don't need a payroll company you
just write a check out of your account
so you're you're a startup one-man show
right
yeah yes sir okay what kind of business
are you doing what are you doing
i'm starting a small messenger of
courier service okay cool
so you get some money in and you throw
it into the checking account
when you get ready to bring some money
out of that checking account
home you set 25 of that
amount over into that savings and the
other 75 percent comes out in
just a personal check written to you
okay out of my business account yeah all
right so you take your business account
there's a thousand dollars in there
that you want to bring some home out of
that business account and pay some bills
or eat and some stuff like that
then you would write a 250 dollar check
in to save and move it over to that
savings account you'd write a 750 dollar
check
and take it home right now does it
strictly have to be a check
it couldn't be did you say it could be
anything
but if you you know however you're going
to do it i mean if you use
how are you going to transfer you could
just do a transfer if it's inside
you know on your website but but just
always keep that 75-25 rule going
because in effect you are withholding
like your employer withholds on you
they hold money out for taxes and that's
what we're doing with that 25
going over into savings right and pay
that quick and then that becomes my
quarterly
exactly and that becomes and that
becomes the equivalent of a payroll
company doing withholding that's why you
don't need a payroll company at this
stage
fantastic i wouldn't screw with the
payroll company until you have employees
got it and then it's then it's worth it
using one to not have to mess with
the irs calculations for all the
employees which will drive you freaking
bananas
that's another story though yeah that's
thank goodness very well
you have listened to some of the entree
leadership materials very carefully
scotty and you've done a great job with
that
so ken uh the reason we've instructed
people to do what scotty's doing that
are opening
solopreneur things is
the number one cause of small business
failure especially a solopreneur
crashing
is cash flow problems cash flow problems
mean you don't have any money
why don't you have any money because you
didn't pay your taxes when you get
behind the irs
or you go into a bunch of debt yeah and
so what we've instructed here is
this is a situation we didn't get into
this part of the conversation but
if this is a side hustle for a while you
know if that's the situation and you
have a day job
then i would just keep loading up that
bank account and
and until it can until you're paying
yourself something that you really can
use
uh just get that company healthy in his
situation where it
may feel like he's doing this full-time
uh and giving it a go
uh having that tax and pulling that
aside and being disciplined there
that's going to help you tremendously as
you learn the ropes of this because the
first time you start a company you
realize there are tax benefits get
yourself a great
ramsey tax advisory and get somebody who
really knows what they're doing
to make sure that you're protecting
yourself because people don't realize
when they work for a regular company
where people pull all this out they just
don't think about it they see the number
anything that's a 1099. yeah i mean if
you're if you're running uh
ubereats yes same thing and they're not
holding taxes out on you
you better pull it aside you're gonna
you know you run ten thousand dollars up
you're gonna get a two thousand
five hundred dollar extra tax bill in
the year and you've got no money for
that
that's gonna bite you in the butt yeah
and that's what happens in a small
business solopreneur startup like that
that's right you can get behind on those
taxes because you act like they're not
there
and live off of all the money that's
right and that's a bad plan
yeah and don't pay yourself if you don't
have i just i get this call a lot of the
ken coleman show just want to point out
if you don't have to pay yourself right
now and you can live off that day job
do it yeah stack some money up in that
side hustle yeah and just let it sit
there or
pull it all out and throw it on your
debt if that's what you're doing if
you're in the debt snowball absolutely
put every nickel towards you
after taxes archely is with us hey
arcelli how are you
hi i'm very well thank you for taking my
call good pronounce your name for me i
destroyed it
it's arisely hey aricelli okay thank you
it was just the sea it was pretty good
i messed it up okay but it's somebody's
name it's important no
no i've i've gotten aerosol and
that's great well i didn't do that yeah
all right how can we help
i have a predicament i'm in the middle
of a divorce
um i get to keep the house my girls are
staying with me
um one's 19 the other one is 17. there's
no
alimony you transport anything into the
equation the house is paid in full
and i am going to pay him out
200 200 000 so my question is
whether i take out a loan to pay him
that amount or my attorney indicated i
could take out
penalty free that money for my 401k i
don't know what to do
which option would be better lose the
interest on my
401k by doing that or
have this other language without the
uncertainty of me now being had a
household
and having your income all the bails and
everything
um when how about 120
okay well i i hate how you got here
i hate how you got here but if you call
me up and set up a 200 000 mortgage on a
15-year fixed rate and i make 120 000
a year and i got two teenagers i
wouldn't be panicked hearing that
but i don't i don't like how we got here
obviously you don't either it's been
painful
exactly um i'm just you know i've always
had the cushion of
having him as a backup um but me now
being this whole hit a household
yeah how old are you that free would
give me 50.
okay so i mean if you take out a 15-year
mortgage of 65 the house is paid for or
sooner if you pay it off early right
yeah and as the kids grow and move out
you know you're going to have more
margin and room in your budget to throw
serious money at this house and get it
paid off early
so yeah i think you take out a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage
okay and don't listen to your attorney
financial advice she's not very smart
no it was just because my i don't you
know coming into having all this
obligation now on me and the
responsibility um i wasn't
if you told me you made 70 000 i'd be
telling you to sell the house you
understand that
okay yeah yeah definitely afford to live
there
because of this horrible situation
you've gone through i'm so sorry
so right thank you no fun at all how
long were you married
22 years how you doing
hanging in there sounds like it
yeah here's what we're going to do i
want you to go through ramsey plus for a
year i'm going to pay for it
which puts you into financial peace
university and puts you into every
dollar premium
and shows you how to handle money
because somebody needs to give you a hug
right now and that's me and ken
okay thank you so much i appreciate it
and i appreciate this advice i've been
one day debating one option one day
debating the other and i'm just
trying to figure out long term what
would be the best well the problem is
none of these options are wonderful
because of a less than wonderful
situation
yeah and so it's it's not good but
you're gonna get through it
and we're going to show you how we'll
walk with you kiddo i'm sorry
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life your money and
with ken here especially your career
yeah looking for jobs uh thinking about
telling the boss to take this job and
well ken can help you
yeah and uh little johnny paycheck
reference there
just gotta brought that in there it
looks like that that's a good idea what
a great song
yeah it's a classic bunch of young
people need you to finish that line
that's the song is take this job and
shove it
yeah and we're trying to help you do
that don't jump don't jump
absolutely find the right job keep
paying off debt you don't have to go
backwards in your debt snowball
you can actually pursue work you've
always wanted to do and not
stop the baby steps there you go we get
that question a lot
which is a it's a natural question i'll
tell you how phone number
eight eight two five five two two five
johnny is with us in san antonio hi
johnny how are you
hey doing great guys how are you doing
better than we deserve what's up
great thanks for taking my call so i'm
uh
in my mid to late 60s and i'm thinking
about retiring
soon and i want to know i've got some
money to say in savings
and i wanted to know if it's better to
put it towards the mortgage or
do some kind of investments ira or and
if you have an elp in san antonio you
would recommend
my income is 75 annual
my wife's social security is about 850 a
month
um we have investments of
we have a fixed annuity of around 40 k
and then ira my wife has an ira of 16k
so that's a total of 56.
cool mortgage is 238 uh
on a 2.75 30 year fixed and we're four
years into it
good for you well as you probably have
heard if you listen for more than about
three minutes we talk about the baby
steps all the time which is the clear
path to wealth
and uh the idea being we're out of debt
so you're out of debt everything but
your house right
right cards are paid for and the house
is the only thing and you have your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses in place your rainy day fund
right
correct good yeah and in savings right
now i've got 33k
and i'm getting another 5 000 bonus good
uh
we do have 5k allocated for a new range
that we need to replace that's the only
major your next goal
is continue putting 15 of your household
income
into retirement and to continue to build
your nest egg and let's get this house
paid off that's baby steps four
and six and so lean into that house and
let's get that thing finished off how
much
you said you got oh 200 and something on
it right yeah 230
paint yeah so let's uh and that becomes
a big goal because if by the time you
quit work if you have a really nice nest
egg
and a paid for house you have a very
stable
situation if when you retire yourself a
home mortgage it's
destabilizing it's less than stable
because you've got that stinking payment
laying there staring at you
and uh it changes the last 30 years of
your life to live in a paid for house
dramatically
so well done you're on your way tamron
is in new york city
hey tamron welcome to the ramsey show
thank you so much for having me how are
you doing today
better than i deserve how can we help
i am calling i recently i have a
question
that relates to college and when
it is okay or sensible to
derail the plan and borrow for college
my husband and i we actually didn't even
discover
your system until during the pandemic
and we've paid down a lot of debt we
sold a rental property
um set up our emergency fund wonderful
we made a lot of progress in one year
well selling the selling the rental
property gave us a
large sum and we're blessed to have
terrific careers
but my oldest son is a senior in high
school this year
and last year he expressed an interest
that his dream school was
a prestigious private university that's
around here i graduated law school from
there myself
so um tugged at my heart and i was
supportive of him that if he did
everything that was necessary
and got the grades and kept everything
up as long as he
could get scholarships and aid and the
out-of-pocket expenses
for us was less than 25 000 a year that
we could afford to pay
cash through the school's payment plan
and that
he could go there my sophomore
however he had some trouble
when he started high school last year
and he was getting into trouble
and he was making poor decisions and
then when they closed the schools down
he
kind of continued to go down a scary
path from our perspective
and he asked us if he could go away to a
boarding school to a military school
that's not too far from where we live
and
seeing that that was best for him we
immediately in december
agreed and enrolled him and sent him but
i'm now paying
2500 a month for him to go to school
and our budget only has
after all of the bills and essentials
like food and you know clothing allows
and haircuts like really the full budget
only has about four thousand dollars to
spare in it
what's your household in i don't know um
right now we're at about 240
and i will be wrapping up my um
clerkship my post law school clerkship
so i would expect that next year
it'll be um closer to 300 if not over
300
which will give you the money to send
the other one
mm-hmm yeah and that's why i was there's
not a plan where i dig
back and forth to answer your earlier
question there's not a plan where i put
you into student loans
okay there's two options here one is we
figure this out or junior picks a
different school
okay and his future is not ruined based
on that
and pause listen pause is doesn't mean
never doesn't mean stop it's he could do
his first year somewhere else in
three years three through four yeah uh
or two through four
at the at the uh dream prestige school
again if he lines up all the
scholarships
and it's 25 000 out of pocket with no
student loans
he can also work towards this you know i
mean he understands what's going on in
the family and assuming you guys are
there's some harmony there and he's as
healthy as an 18 17 eight year old can
be about his brother's situation
he can work and kind of help out you
know with this process as well and say
hey here's where i think this is a
family meeting i think you sit him down
he says
he knows what's going on and just say
hey here's where we are
this is reality student loans is not an
option we're not going to do that
that's what dad and i have been doing
you've seen us getting out of debt
bring him into the bigger picture and
say hey life happens sometimes
this is a you know it's not fair it's
right it's sad and you didn't do
anything wrong
uh and yet it's affecting you but still
it is affecting you and so here's what
we're going to do
uh let's pretend that you're you lost
your job
and you you couldn't send him to that
school you'd have the same conversation
and it wouldn't be his fault
you know you would have lost your job
and he would have to deal with that kids
kids can deal with this so hold on we're
going to send you a copy of anthony's
book debt-free degree i want you all to
read that as a family
and i want you to commit to working some
kind of a cash flow game plan
to some school that you pay cash for
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
i know what it feels like to think
you're never going to be able to save
money
[Music]
i know what it feels like to think
you're never going to get out of debt
but you can actually do it and we can
show you how
it's what we do inside of ramsey plus
ramsey plus is our step-by-step plan
that gets you quick
wins so you can make faster progress on
your debt and once that debt's gone for
good
you get more money back in your pocket
the best part is you can try it for free
once you become a member you'll also get
benefits like the
federal classic e-file with ramsey smart
tax free included the audiobook of
rachel cruz's brand new bestseller know
yourself know your money
free included and of course financial
peace university and of course
every dollar premium version and of
course you're going to finally get your
money under control and we're going to
show you
exactly how to do that
you can try it for free but before
before becoming a member just go to
daveramsey.com
ramseyplus and check out the free trial
daveramsey.com ramsey plus
riverside california is on the line ken
is calling hi ken how are you
hey hi dave hi ken thanks for taking my
call
sure how can we help so it's going to
start off sounding like a sob story it's
going to turn out with a good ending
i've
i've actually become debt free
went through a disability thing with
with a failed back surgery
turning 53 next week but dave i've done
fpu coordinating multiple times
i'm just here to tell you as everybody
does that your principles work the baby
steps work and if i can do it anybody
can
when i went from being you know high on
the hog owning a
successful business to disabled i lost a
lot
but i didn't lose hope and i kept
plugging away i kept
you know doing the fpu coordinating even
after all that
and they've i've counseled people i've
helped people out
the principles work obviously i enjoy
helping people here's my question i
won't ramble on too long
i'm looking at the coaching program
i've always done financial coaching as a
ministry though i've never charged for
it
and turning 53 next week i'm getting up
there i am disabled
my income is only just under 2 000 a
month here in california which being
debt free
mortgage and everything is a good thing
i'm just wondering with ken there
you know with the career and everything
else is it a good idea for someone in my
situation
to save up might take me six months to a
year to do it
to get that certification to do it as a
ministry
well uh ministry or would you charge for
it when you say ministry what does that
mean i've never
charged i've always just done the
financial coaching for free it's just
something that i've enjoyed giving back
doing
i really feel like with my story it's
very relatable a lot of people feel like
wow
anybody can and stay positive you know
yeah
well look when somebody asks me is this
a good career move i walk them through
the sweet spot analogy which is very
simple
our creator gave people talent things
you do well and you're supposed to use
those as tools to do work that you love
that fires you up when you think about
it when you do it and then
allows you to accomplish to produce
results that
mean something to you we know that this
means something to you so the question
is if i talk to everybody that knows you
can when they say that you're a good
communicator
yes yes people are calling me all the
time i know
i'm helping people in my family right
now that's right and you're good at
instruction which is what it takes to be
a good coach communication
and you got to be good at communication
you got to be good at instruction you
got to have a heart for people
you have all three of those so the
answer is yeah this is a good move i i
would just challenge you i have no
problem with you doing it
uh pro bono or as a ministry
uh but i just sit here and look at your
situation and i think you could uh
because there's no financial pressure on
you to make money as a financial coach
that's a good thing
because this takes time to build this
this is a one-to-one we build one client
at a time
um i just wonder why you wouldn't
eventually charge because our
our team can not only train you how to
be a really great coach but how to build
your business are you opposed to it
no no i just never have i've done
hundreds of
appointments you know and i i think
you're i think you're going to do some
of both if i'm you
uh-huh yeah i think you're going to
start charging for some and then
occasionally you're going to see someone
you just need to help and you just want
to do that
and you just want to give them a leg up
and you want to get them started but the
the ramsey preferred coaches who have
gone through all of the training
and then that we send leads to some of
them are making pretty substantial
incomes
the top ones are and so let's just
pretend let's just say you made a
hundred thousand dollars a year doing
this for fun
uh then you could also give away a bunch
of your services
as well right sure sure yeah
there's no reason you can't do both so
here's what we're going to do i'm going
to pay for it i want you to go through
the time
that's great you need to go through the
training oh my gosh
seriously you've earned it you you're
the man i mean you've got listen
having a testimony is a wonderful thing
getting one's a pain in the butt
the truth and you have been through
that's the truth and so yeah i want you
to go through the training is something
i don't usually give away it's a pretty
expensive item but
uh madison pick up and we'll get him
through the first series of courses i
you can talk to the coaching team and
figure out what what the proper way to
get him started on this is a
and uh just tell them i said this is it
this one's a gift on me
that's so cool you know see i got you
know what you see what i just did there
it's what i told him to do yeah go make
a bunch of money yep
and give some away give some of it away
yeah because he's going to be in a
situation where he can uh
he can do financial coaching for
somebody who maybe is going through
something he went through yeah
a physical injury that rocks your world
wow and i got to tell you man
it's dad gum pain and
medical bills are we seeing them in our
counseling office our coaching offices
every day all across america yeah
it's a it's a real real thing without a
doubt
jean is with us in colorado springs hi
gene welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
without going into all the glory details
um my husband and i have separate
accounts
um we just put the house in both our
names
i have no debt he already had a home
equity loan on the house
plus a car loan now he wants to borrow
more money to buy some firearms
and with the hosting in both our names
it's
joint tennis not survivorship i would
have to find
some papers to say i could
consent to him getting a lien on the
house
should i do it to buy guns
yes how old are you guys
i'm 68 and he's 76. and how long have
you been married
over 15 years okay i have a huge gun
collection i'm a gun guy i can't
possibly imagine borrowing on my house
to buy a freaking gun
i'm a gun guy i'm your husband okay i
would i would be on his side but i can't
possibly imagine what
what gun purchase there could be that
justifies borrowing on your personal
home to buy it
what is he buying a tank no
they're um single shot high wall
low wall whatever um and
he went to us he went to a gun shop and
they had these great deals and he knows
he could get
a lot of money off selling them
yeah he doesn't need to get in the
firearms business
at 76 years old by borrowing on his home
no i i don't think this is a good plan
and if he called me i would tell him
not to do it and so i'm going to tell
you not to allow your home to be done
because when this all goes out sideways
and he can't sell these guns
uh for whatever reason as an individual
or a collector or whatever he's getting
into here i can't tell what the flip
he's getting
into but uh it must be in a very
expensive collectible gun of some kind
of sound it sounds like he got a great
deal he thinks oh i can buy this now
hold on from a gun shop
he's going to steal it from a gun shop
yeah like they're going to give him a
deal so he can make a lot on it i got
questions yeah
i'm thinking ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding warning warning warning
because that's what retailers are known
for dave yeah they're known for giving
things away at cheap so you can make
more money on it later
yeah gun shops are known for not having
no idea the value of the guns in their
shops
we're being sarcastic your husband's
plan
sucks don't get into debt to do it
and that's from a couple of gun guys oh
my gosh wow
can't believe i told somebody not buy a
gun i know just happened right here
yeah that's harder than telling them not
by a boat
wow this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our question today comes from blinds.com
a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more always use the
magic word
the promo code ramsey
today's question comes from amy nebraska
she writes in i have a job interview
coming up for an entry level position as
an assistant manager
for a coffee chain if salary is not
brought up by my interviewer
when is the best time for me to ask
about it you ask about it when they
offer you the job
because presumably not always but
presumably
when they offer you the job amy they're
going to tell you
what they are offering the job at as an
hourly rate and at that point
then you can discuss that but i would
not ask about it early on i always tell
people dave in the interview process
uh you want to convince that hiring
manager that you will help them win
we've got to remember that
they're people too and they're looking
for somebody that's going to help them
win and so there will come a time in
this particular question
where uh the uh the hourly rate the
salary whatever that is is going to come
up
completely through the interview and
you're walking out of your first
interview and you still have no
idea what the pay is you don't ask well
fair question but in this situation um
you can
you have a good idea what an hourly rate
is going to be at a coffee shop you have
a pretty good idea and you can find that
out
pretty easily you have a ballpark range
i mean it's not going to be something
like
seven eight nine dollars an hour you're
probably going to be in that low range
would be 10
with the minimum wage politicizing
that's going on right now you're
probably going to be
in that 12 to 15 an hour so you
shouldn't walk into an interview like
that going
i have no idea what i can and can't do
so it's a good point to bring up but you
have
to have an eye an eye on the type of
work and do your homework prior to the
job that's what i teach
you can find out what people are paying
you can find out if it's a good coffee
shop to work at before you ever show up
so i agree with the general sentiment
that you would not
uh if someone i teach our guys here in
recruiting
if they lead with what do you pay what
are the benefits
just end the interview yeah totally
agree because they're here for what they
can take not what they can give
yeah and so it's over yeah and so that's
the other end of that sentiment
right uh uh but i i would be perfectly
careful at the end of the interview if
nothing has been brought up
to start with that's a really sucky
interviewer
that does not cover some of what's going
on that is true
that is true but uh if that's the case
uh you get to the end of it and just go
hey i really appreciate our time our
conversation
i think i can add value here if this
were to work out what is the
general yeah i'm playing with that i'm
fine with that what's the range i'm fine
with it or something like that yes just
so i kind of
so i kind of know what to anticipate and
then you can go
because that you may want to rule them
out yes
you may not want to go through three
interviews and get hired for
half of what you think you're going to
get well you're not going to go through
three interviews for an hourly wage like
this for an actual
job so i that is good context that i
agree with
my point is this when you're going for
an entry level position you need to have
already done your homework on that place
do they treat people like they're just
robots and
soulless people and they're just moving
burn and churn through this
do some homework find out is this a
great place to work you can do that
very easily it's not difficult with all
the resources we have in this world
so with that being the context i'm
always wanting people to show up at that
interview
and and absolutely blow them away so
that they go they want you
and the time comes that's good practice
for a real job
it is because you're not going to bring
up salary you're going to bring that up
in the first time
you better not i mean it's bad i mean i
had a young guy i'll never forget
one of the way back i mean we had 10
people
and we had this young guy i ran into him
i was speaking to church he came up he
was real enthusiastic afterwards i was
talking to him for 20 minutes
and i said you know he said are you
you're hiring for anything i said yeah
yeah and he came over and he sat down
it was so disappointing because he was
such a rock star in
so many ways but the first thing out of
his mouth is okay what's this pay
yeah and what are your benefits
packaging it makes me cringe-hearing
it's because because he you know he
instantly revealed his heart
yes which is i'm here to take rather
than to add
yes and i can't come into the business i
own
with that attitude yeah i'm here to what
can i take versus what can i add
you better put some water in the bucket
or there'll be no water in the bucket
and remember for entry-level jobs you're
up against a lot of people
it's a factory so i want you to put your
best foot forward i'm not i like what
you said
i'd be okay with that but i want you to
win the position
when they're trusting confidence when
they offer it then you say
you're probably going to do that in that
first interview yeah
because to your point to your point
they're not going to do six interviews
like and they're shuffling people
through
and uh so you wanna be classy you know
did you fog up the mirror okay yeah
well in some places that's the case yeah
if yeah
you can get higher smiles pass the drug
test and fog up a mirror
yes you don't even have to smile i can
prove that by some of the people that
serve coffee so i'm just telling you
bad experience dave oh i won't bring up
a brand new
dart sierra in orlando
hey sierra how are you i'm well good
afternoon how are you guys
better than we deserve how can we help
i have a question about taxes
um this is the first year that i will be
doing mostly contract work
i worked as a pa a physician assistant
and i reached out to i think two elps
or three and i got kind of three
different answers and i'm just confused
one of them recommended that i open an
llc
no and then pay myself no
okay i didn't like it the other one said
yes open the llc pay your own payroll
company
no but they're wanting money monthly and
the third
said just pay 25 every three months
to the irs ding ding ding there's your
answer that's the one you want
okay yeah you what i would tell you to
do is just
open a separate checking account in your
social security number it's a dba
doing business ask and you have a little
separate business account and you put
all of your income
into that business account when you want
to pull money out of that and take it
home to
buy things at home or pay bills at home
or pay debt at home or whatever
you'd hold back 25 over into a separate
savings account to pay your quarterly
estimates and your problem unless you
make over a hundred thousand dollars a
year 25
will cover it yes it's probably between
eight to ten grand a month
um unfortunately there is an llc now
open
that's okay it's not the end of the
world if you want to run it through that
now that you did it that's okay
because it'll have its own ein number
and you just run it through that you can
but it serves exactly the same purpose
you just added
the paperwork and the expense of the llc
to the process and now you've also added
a new tax return to the process because
you get the file tax return on the llc
so you get to file a tax return plus the
llc file files one so you've
i want to ask you about that day for her
shouldn't she just shut that down then
why go through all those extra steps i
mean i know she opened it she paid money
probably for somebody else yeah
you know it's just not that big it's not
worth it it's just
it's a hassle because you got one extra
tax return yeah but
um yeah you know you're gonna have a
schedule c
on your uh personal return if you don't
do the llc
so you've got some forms to fill out
anyway so for taxes so
you know uh it's not the end of the
world to do that i definitely would not
use a payroll company to pay yourself
that's nightmarish uh but uh
i i don't recommend solopreneurs unless
they have
lots of money an llc is not there for
tax purposes it's there for
risk management it's there for if that
company gets sued
you don't want to be the individual that
owns it so as an example
i actually own absolutely nothing now
i don't own a thing it's all in llc's
in corporations and trusts
and all of my real estate is uh my cars
are even in an llc so if there's a car
wreck
you can sue the company that owns the
cars because that's who owns them
i don't know and so you know the
liability it's a
risk management tool is all it is it's
to get the risk down it is not to get
taxes off of you
so i don't use llc's for tax purposes
they don't really serve one
in her situation get educated on all
those write-offs of being a 1099 or
contractor yeah you'd be surprised how
much you can write off
now that your good your tax elp would be
great for
absolutely this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day romans 8 18 for
i consider that the sufferings of this
present time are not worth comparing
with the glory that is to be revealed to
us
robert hughes said the struggle you're
in today is developing the strength you
need tomorrow
well that's the truth brandon's with us
in salt lake city hi brandon how are you
hi i'm doing great how about you guys
better than we deserve how can we help
wow it's a pleasure to be talking to you
both i'm very thankful for the
opportunity you guys are at
uh to help me out i i'm uh i'm currently
in the job application process
i'm a senior in college and
i'm currently i so i've applied to a
position that i really
really would like for a large
corporation
but the one problem is i'm trying to be
proactive and
trying to contact the or anyone a
recruiter
just to say hey this is my job
application trying to stand out from all
these
from all these candidates but i can't
find a recruiter
because there's there's hundreds of them
in this company
i do have a contact for i'm actually
connected with the person i'd be
applying for
um on linkedin right but i i'm
i don't know if it would be wrong for me
just to jump the whole recruitment
process
oh yeah and contact them directly oh
yeah but
ken's going to tell you how to do that
yeah yeah yeah
well what do you what are you worried
about if you reach out to them directly
you're going to get like they're going
to blackball is that what you're talking
about
yeah kind of like oh this is annoying
he's just he's not following the
game and you've already applied you've
already applied correct
that's correct i applied about a week
ago yes yeah well it's a major company
so they've got a big big system and
they've got a process
so you know one way you could go about
this that i think would not get you in
hot water
you've got the person who's hiring
linkedin information so
you're pretty resourceful young man i do
a handwritten note just something simple
hey
just want to let you know i've applied
recently and uh
love the company if i ever get the
opportunity to work here here's why i'd
want to work here really
short sweet yeah let me give you another
line to enter into that okay yeah go
ahead
and just in that note go hey and there's
a fine line
between showing initiative and being
just weird i want to be right near that
line
he acknowledged that you've done some
homework yeah but i'm okay with that
because a handwritten note is not creepy
no you find their email and they're
wondering how in the world you get that
but if i read that and i'm the executive
on the other side i'm gonna go that's
funny
yes i like this i love that dave that's
a great suggestion very very good
i think the handwritten note is the way
i would go but now what i would really
work on is through all of your contacts
yeah here we go here this is the
proximity principle and we're looking at
your web of connections we know from
sociology research
that the number one way to get jobs is
through
acquaintances so get outside of your
family and friends that's that close
personal network picture spiderweb
we're gonna go out okay so now we're
looking at everybody we know on social
media
how many people you think they know so
let's just i'm using this example let's
say you got 500 friends on facebook
well how many friends do each of those
500 500 have
and you've got to get aggressive there
and just ask for people to help you
don't be weird does anybody know anybody
that works
at x boom i'm applying i've already
applied a company xyz do you know
anybody that works there and let's see
what that yields and then i would go to
the personal context
outside of social media same deal reach
out to everybody you know hey
i just want a shot at an interview
that's not asking too much
that's not creepy that's not arrogant
that shows
desire and you'd be surprised what that
will yield but you got to really work
hard
um and and then let the chips fall where
they fall on the official submission
because
you're going to go through the system
i'd have you look at the ken coleman
resume guide
uh we've got six templates in addition
to the free one
at the resume guide uh at my website
kencoleman.com check that out
submit the resume that way you know
stand out let's just give it to him
it's it doesn't yeah that's free madison
oh matt that was
six templates give him the six templates
yeah give him the six templates free
and use those to reach in yeah and uh
then
and he's also if you'll read the stuff
at the downloads that are free at
kingcoleman.com
it'll show you how to build the letter
to getting contact now i'll add one
other thing to ken's system which
ken system is flawless but it's almost
an old sales technique i used to use
if you do get an actual interview
during the interview ask
when you should follow up and set an
appointment
for the follow-up love that that way
you're not
pestering it that way you're just
following through on what you said and
they said well you know we'll know in a
couple of weeks would it be okay if i
contacted you
on friday the 14th and they will say yes
and then when you call on friday the
14th they go yes brandon said he was
going to call
he called that's a good sign for him but
also then you're not trying to chase
somebody in phone tag
or you're not trying to you know you're
not worried that you're pestering them
on a follow-up yeah because the
follow-up is set you schedule
your follow-up and then it's not
pestering it's expected
then let it go i mean one of the worst
things you can do is just keep emailing
somebody
look if they want you trust me they're
going to get back to you do a great job
do your best job in the interview do a
follow-up we have a touch point timeline
free guy
get six other places to go after while
you're going after this that's right
don't sit around and wait
good idea yeah so hold on
madison will pick up and she'll get you
those templates and a copy of ken's book
the proximity principle
we're going to set you up man for going
to get the job you want and listen i
need you to call ken coleman on his show
uh and let him know if you get this job
using these techniques
i want to hear the story yeah we get a
lot of fun emails this stuff really does
work
and here's the other thing you know if
it doesn't work let's let's let's really
figure out how
to open up our connections because what
people don't know dave is is
that they know everybody they already
need to know i know that seems
intimidating it's the one degree of
separation
it really is yeah it's when i was a kid
we played this thing called the match
game
you got grandkids now yeah but they
still have the matches we played with
our kids
oh good and and so it's this idea of
what you just start turning over the
tiles and we go okay i saw an elephant
here i'm looking for another elephant
that's the it's the simplicity of i've
got to be diligent
i know everybody i need to know i got to
keep talking about it i got to keep
asking people will help if we ask the
right way
yeah that's exactly right and
don't folks that are out there okay
there's a lot of people looking for jobs
and ken can coach you on this
you can get all the details you need
ramsey solutions will hire 340 people
this year if we meet our hiring goals
however we will have 25 000
applications come in if you simply fill
out an application and that's all you
ever do
there is a high probability that we will
have missed out
on hiring you it's true might as well
play the lottery while you're doing that
it's really a long shot in today's world
with so many people applying for
so this thing of i filled out a hundred
thousand applications on monster.com and
not on one call me back well no crap
not a one did you know or i used
ziprecruiter and did all this multiple
filings at one time
and zip recruiter is great we advertise
for them yeah but
but you cannot just mass
you know just throw enough mud against
the wall to see if something sticks
you've got to find that singular
connective spot
with someone that knows someone that
knows someone inside
and uh you know joe's friend works over
there and joe's friend's name's
sally and sally is gonna get you know at
least
have a connectivity point well here's
another thing i got an email
at the last break that a friend of mine
had sent
a lady who wants to work here right and
send
her and i send him over to hr sure and
that doesn't mean she's going to get
hired
but she's not in the stack anymore oh no
she's at the top
she's atop the pocket well she she maybe
at the top of the wrong pile right you
know but she's in well she's getting it
look she's not gonna she's getting a
look that's the issue there's gonna be a
real consideration
chances go up when we get interviews
we're trying to get an interview
one thing we get all the time uh on the
on the ken coleman show dave is people
say okay ken i did what you said i
really truly don't
have a connection to somebody in the
company and so
the next best thing is with the resume
guide and the resume templates at
kencombo.com we have flipped our resume
and the hrc could you send that to that
guy and only
but here's what yeah absolutely you can
reach out but what we've done
in our resume and our hr team has worked
with me on this we've got a world-class
hr team at ramsey solutions
the top of our resume dave says who i
know so if you don't have a connection
to somebody
in the company let's use ramsey
solutions example then maybe you should
get a great endorsement from somebody
who is a world-class uh financial
advisor
smart investor pro who we may not know
personally but they're in our network or
if you're going into technology get a
great
reference from somebody who's a big shot
in that field it'll make them go huh
yep they look at you that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
you